Australia's worst bushfire season on
record looks set to become a whole lot
worse Saturday brought even hotter
temperatures and more strong winds to
much of the country Fanning hundreds of
blazes already burning out of control so
it's going to be a very long afternoon a
very long evening and and as that
southerly approaches it's going to be a
gusty so Lee it's going to be a
southerly it's going to be a volatile
solid southerly with wind strengths
expected to be up to 80 kilometers or
more gusting along the coastal strip
more than 100,000 people were told to
leave their homes across three states
while there was still a chance to get
away
not everyone managed on kangaroo island
two people died as their car was
overtaken by a blaze that broke
containment lines Australia's prime
minister says the fire crisis has
reached a new level and has ordered 3000
Army reservists to help scale of the
fires is stretching resources on the
ground and there are clearly communities
that need additional help and in
response to that we must move forward
first as a Commonwealth particularly
with the work of our defense forces and
then integrate with the local operations
that are in place in those local
communities the announcement comes after
weeks of intense and politically
bruising criticism for the prime
minister who has so far insisted that
managing the fires was a matter for
individual States and Rural Fire
Services alone fire services that have
been stretched to the limit the
Australian Navy has also been deployed
to help with the evacuation of fire
affected coastal areas
these people were the first to be
rescued from mallacoota in the state of
Victoria where a mega blaze forced 4000
people to flee to the waterfront on New
Year's Eve many of them are still
trapped in the town waiting for rescue
as smoke from the fires once again
turned day and tonight